the opening scene begins with a girl
named woo shawen sleeping beside her
grandmother just then a phone call
awakens her and she tries to wake up her
grandmother however despite several
attempts the old woman doesn't wake up
because she's frakin dead in the next
scene we are introduced to a Carefree
man named Mo senme who is sending some
voice messages to his angry girlfriend
shishi during this he receives a call
from his friend Wang informing him of a
death case and summoning him to prepare
the dead body for the funeral here it's
revealed that San May handles his family
business called kingon Funeral Parlor
where the dead bodies are prepared for
the final rights a while later San
arrives at shaan's house where he starts
cleaning her grandmother's body shaen is
seen hiding inside a closet and peeping
through a hole when she sees s touching
her grandmother she walks out with a
stick and starts beating him up angrily
as a result her uncle carries her away
and locks her in another room with a boy
sanme then continues his work and soon
prepares to load the body in their van
just then the grandmother's
daughter-in-law notices that her gold
ring is missing knowing that sanme had
previously been impr prisoned she takes
no time to accuse him of stealing the
ring however sanme claims that he didn't
and to prove his innocence he takes off
his clothes asking her to check if she
wants a fantastic scheme if he did in
fact put the ring up his ass despite
being unconvinced the daughter-in-law
walks away regarding him as a pervert
afterwards shaen watches her grandmother
being put into a coffin and loaded in a
van the boy beside her says that her
grandmother will be burnt into ashes and
hence she'll never see her again upon
hearing this the kid jumps out of the
window and starts running after the van
after taking the body to The Cremation
site San May arrives home he is
discussing their property ownership with
his father when he receives a text from
his girlfriend it turns out that shishi
has ended their relationship via Chad
Furious San drives to her clothing store
and bangs on the door as soon as shishi
opens the door he carries her on his
shoulders and takes her to the bedroom
he forcibly demands an explanation but
at the same time another man walks out
of her bathroom realizing that she was
cheating on him sanme gets into a
physical brawl with the guy however
shishi stops him and announces that
she's pregnant with this man's baby she
further explains that sanme lacks the
maturity to be good father which is the
reason why she wants to break up this
deeply saddens San May prompting him to
walk away with a heavy heart following
this sanme returns home only to find
shaen who asks about her grandmother's
whereabouts sanme is in no mood to deal
with her so he simply brushes her off
and walks inside shortly after shaan's
Uncle arrives at the scene and takes her
away sanme now burdened with his own
troubles sits in front of his home
lighting a Sig during this moment one of
his his neighbors approaches him and
invites him to join his wedding business
claiming that it's better to send people
to wedding beds than Heaven there's a
good chance for him to say deathbeds and
complete the analogy but he screwed it
up however distressed sanme rejects him
with a rude reply later that evening
shaen returns to s's doorstep
persistently asking about her
grandmother her uncle also arrives to
collect her but the little girl refuses
to leave left with no options he
requests San to look after shaan for 3
days sanme declines asserting that this
place is not an orphanage however Wang
agrees when shaan's Uncle offers money
in the next scene San's female friend B
Shu provides the girl with a meal later
the four of them play a card game during
which shaen shows her grandmother's ring
she admits that she stole it to prevent
her aunt from confiscating it at
midnight sanme is awakened by something
dripping from above much to his disgust
the little girl has wet her bed which
enrages him he scolds her for her
actions before placing the wet sheets
into the washing machine following this
sanme is forced to spend the rest of the
night on a couch in the morning he
receives a call from his sister who
summons him to visit a government office
with property ownership documents
hearing this he suddenly realizes that
he inadvertently washed away the
documents along with the bed sheets last
night as a result sanme has to wait one
more month to inherit his father's
property while at the government office
s May receives a call from Wang calling
him to the hospital to pick up another
dead body for a funeral San May who is
already overwhelmed with his problems
vents his desire to shut down the
funeral business his father over hears
this and beats him with a stick forcing
him to continue his work after this San
proceeds to the hospital where he finds
shaen who has arrived with Wang she
constantly inquires about her
grandmother irritating s me further to
keep her mouth shut he promises to take
her to visit her grandmother mother only
if she obeys him he then takes her to a
room where the dead body is kept it
turns out that a little girl has
succumbed to her illness leaving the
parents devastated in a strategic move
to secure the funeral contract against
competitors sanme approaches the crying
parents he introduces shaan as his
daughter and claims that he's working
for Good Karma rather than money this
lie ultimately helps him to win the
contract they all then arrive at the
funeral parlor and San instructs xiaan
to remain in the car the little girl
tries to refuse but right then she's
drawn to a coffin resembling her
grandmother's and begins to chase after
it she Ventures inside the funeral house
and causes a riot at someone else's
funeral as a consequence of her actions
sanme receives a warning from the
officials and even has to pay a fine
afterwards he takes xiaan back to the
car and scolds her frustrated sanme
points at the chimney explaining that
her grandmother has been cremated into
Ash and turned into smoke kind of like
Santa Claus but instead of being fake
she's dead hearing this the little girl
sobs realizing that she'll never see her
grandmother again back at their home
sand May bashu and Wang console The
Grieving shaen they claim that her
grandmother has become a star in the sky
later on a pink box containing the ashes
of the deceased girl is delivered to
sanme which is to be delivered to her
parents the following morning sanme
wakes up to see shaen painting The Pink
Box freaking him out he hurriedly tries
to to erase it but to no avail now with
no other alternative sanme and Wang set
out to deliver the now painted box they
are a bit scared as they anticipate a
negative response however sanme has
taken back when The Grieving couple
becomes emotional upon seeing the
painted box they mentioned that their
daughter also enjoyed drawing and
expressed their gratitude with bowed
heads Upon returning home The Group
shares some snacks together during this
sanm notices shaen eating snacks from
the floor and reprimands her he then
retrieves some candies from a jar and
shares those with her upon tasting one
he realizes that it's not candy but
rather inedible Pebbles however it's too
late as shaan has already swallowed one
down in a state of panic they rush her
to the hospital where the doctor
reassures them that the pebble will
likely pass out through her butt back at
home the three of them stand outside the
bathroom anxiously waiting for shaen to
finish up as soon as she walks out they
examine the stool and find the ingested
Pebble which provides them with great
relief but they also find three pogs and
a Beyblade which makes them wonder what
year it is 3 days pass by and San May
receives a call from shaan's Uncle
notifying them of their return as a
result San's group visits shaan's
uncle's place where they overhear a
conversation between the couple shaan's
Aunt expresses her reluctance to take
care of the little girl and argues with
her husband about it this prompts San
May to bring shaan back with him as soon
as they reach home he is confronted by
his father for bringing a child to the
funeral house he even threatens to expel
him from the house after this incident
San struggles to sleep and begins
scrolling through his phone during this
he stumbles upon shi's wedding
invitation causing him to fall from his
couch in shock shaen who is also awake
finds this amusing and captures the
moment on her smart watch Uncle sanme is
funny when he's getting cocked the next
morning she asks s's phone number and
promptly sends the photo to him so that
he can always remember the night that
got cocked afterwards sanme Wang and
shaen have breakfast at a local
restaurant during the meal the girl once
again picks up Fallen noodles from the
floor and eats them sanme scolds her for
this Behavior but she runs away without
listening to him shortly after sanme
receives a call from Shawan summoning
him to the park there she introduces him
to an old man Mr Leu who wants to
conduct a funeral for himself San
refuses saying that he can't do that to
someone who's still alive however he
eventually agrees when the old man
offers him a lot of money of course in
the next scene they begin preparations
for Mr Leo's staged funeral by renting
costumes and hiring paid attendees on
the day of the funeral everything goes
well until Mr Leo's family suddenly
arrives and has sanme and his friends
arrested thankfully they're released as
it was Mr Leo's deliberate decision as
they exit the police station they find
Mr Leo on the stairs he confides in them
revealing that his family is in constant
conflict over his property hence he
wanted to spend all of his money to stop
the conflict later as the group returns
home they find San's father in a fit of
extreme anger wreaking havoc around the
house he chastises sanay for conducting
a funeral for a living person in
response our guy loses it and Spills his
heart out he asserts that no matter what
he does he's always wrong in his
father's eyes unfortunately this only
enrages his family and his sister slaps
him before leaving with their father
later that night San approaches the
crying shaen in her bed when asked she
expresses remorse for always getting him
in trouble sanme then consoles her and
tells her to go to sleep the next
morning he hears a neighboring boy
reciting poetry which makes him realize
that shaen should probably also attends
school following this sanme approaches
shaan's Uncle to discuss this matter as
they chat he inquires about shaan's
parents and learns that her mother
passed away shaan's Uncle expresses
shame for not being able to care for her
and asks sanme to adopt her however
sanme due to his unmarried status isn't
eligible for adoption seeking a solution
he visits B shu's place and finds Wang
there as well they finally disclose a
hidden truth they've been married
secretly all this time this Revelation
astonishes s may but he's also happy
that his two friends can now legally
adopt shaen finally they complete all
the necessary paperwork to enroll shaen
in school one day s May's ex-girlfriend
shows up at his doorstep with the tragic
news of her husband's demise she seeks
his help for the funeral but he
hesitates due to his strained
relationship with his father and because
she's an upon hearing this
shawen steps forward volunteering to
mediate the situation the little girl
takes sanme to his father in the park
and encourages them to talk luckily the
plan works and the Father and Son end up
reconciling their differences following
this sanme along with his father and w
heads to the morg to prepare his
ex-lover's deceased husband's body for
the funeral for the funeral senme almost
vomits upon witnessing the gruesome
condition of the body but his father
motivates him to do it following his
father's instructions he eventually
completes the task earning him respect
from shishi but at the same time his
father suddenly collapses to the ground
and he is quickly rushed to the hospital
a while later the old man regains
Consciousness prompting sanman his
sister to rck rush to his side the
father expresses pride in San's growing
sense of responsibility he also reveals
that he loves his son very much and that
he's proud of him the father's going to
die soon for sure later that evening
when San returns home he finds shawen
studying beneath the glow of a table
lamp he switches on the room light and
shawen welcomes him happily as the days
pass San May becomes increasingly
dedicated to his funeral business
investing all his efforts into its
success once in a while he also takes
the little girl for a vacation on the
beach amidst this sanay tries to
retrieve a recording of Shen's
grandmother's voice from her damaged
Smartwatch upon collaborating with the
it experts he finally manages to recover
the tape on Shen's birthday sanme
presents her with a toy which now has
her grandmother's voice hearing this the
little girl bursts into tears of joy and
hugs sanme who also has tears in his
eyes one day after dropping sha went off
at school sam s is approached by shaan's
uncle and a woman who claims herself to
be shaan's biological mother San is
skeptical but the woman provides
detailed information about shaan's birth
and her past circumstances she also
explains that she was imprisoned abroad
hence she was presumed dead despite this
sanme remains unsure and walks away that
night the woman again shows up at his
residence and requests the return of her
child in response sanme tells her that
he cannot decide alone as his two
friends have adopted shawen he then asks
for a 3-day period to contemplate the
matter during these 3 days senme makes
good use of his time with shaen he
prepares meals for her and even attends
her school events posing as her parent
while enjoying a school program shaan
expresses that she is no longer afraid
of never seeing her grandmother again
because she now has a father this fills
Sam's eyes with tears on the third night
shaan's biological mother arrives to
take her her back San packs her
belongings and explains everything about
the child to the woman including her
sleeping positions he has become so
possessive that he even warns her to
take good care of the little girl their
conversation awakens xiaan who addresses
San as her father however the woman
abruptly takes her away and the taxi
departs overwhelmed by emotions sanme
chases after the taxi in the rain but he
fails to catch up because it's a car and
he just has legs the next day Wang and
baiu expressed their frustration at
San's decision to let shawen go without
consulting them shortly after sanme
receives a call from his sister
informing him of their father's passing
San is now devastated by the loss of
both his father and shawen he and his
sister then prepare their father for his
final rights the old man left them a
note expressing his final wish for an
inexpensive but dignified funeral San's
sister suggests burying their father
next to their mother but he rejects the
idea moments later he grabs the
container holding his father's ashes and
drives away with his friends they pull
over at a beach and San sets his
father's ashes a blaze in a tube this
causes it to burst into a firework in
the sky thus fulfilling his father's
last wish for a dignified funeral and
there you have it the only way to make a
funeral inexpensive is to just blow the
ashes up while everyone watches the
fireworks San receives a call informing
him that shaan is missing filed with
concern San his friends and shaan's
biological mother wander every street in
search of the little girl however they
fail to find any trace of her in the
evening they returned to San's home with
heavy hearts just then they hear the
little girl calling his name hastily
exiting the car sanme scolds her for her
actions however he is unable to stay
angry for much longer so he wipes her
tears and Embraces her tightly in the
final scene Wang and by Shu throw a
wedding party at the same time shaan's
mother arrives to drop off her
daughter's belongings she has decided to
let shaen live with s and his friends we
all love sanme but hard to imagine a
mother doing that though before
departing sanme invites her to join
their funeral business so that she can
be close to her daughter the movie ends
as they all sit Outdoors gazing up at
the stars in the night sky subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching